her father Dan had been on television
very stoic very calm very trusting in
the police this entire time it's
certainly not the result they wanted no
I mean this is every I just said to you
every parent's worst nightmares every
human beings worst nightmare I mean this
is an innocent young woman with her
whole life ahead of her never take
another breath of oxygen again because
of what this was what this man's alleged
to have done but I think here early in
the case there was it was a clue here
that said to me that this guy may have
been a suspect earlier than the police
let on
and obviously they owe us nothing they
owe the investigation everything but
remember early on in the case where they
said there may be some miscommunication
here someone may have interacted with
her and they may have assumed something
that says to me that they may have
suspected this person early on and
suspected it was a kidnapping and she
may have still been alive because
they're very strategic in their public
communications through surrogates in
that case one of the family members so
he may have been a suspect very early in
the case any other comments well I I
just in terms of what is important I
think no one at the Trump rally tonight
will give a damn about man afford or
Cohen but this will probably be fresh in
their minds all right are you tell me
what we need to go no okay Dagan your
comment no this is something that
resonates with every parent every mother
father sister brother everybody across
this country and people will be asking
over the dinner table tonight
why was this man in this country why was
this man and why are we still asking
this question after Kate Steinle and
with the rhetoric from the left of we
need to get rid of ice immigrations and
Customs Enforcement that we need that
that we need to get rid of this critical
law enforcement atom unit within the
federal government that's what people
are going to be talking about because
rather than two bad white-collar
criminals quite frankly I don't think
that's right I mean we've had a major
day of breaking news in terms of what I
think are building blocks that are
leading towards what I expect to be a
tumultuous stormy end of this month and
beginning of September for the President
of the United States and I don't know
how you can exceed that you know the
horror that that young
and went through in I was not to be
understated but what we're seeing is
it's becoming politicized much like the
Kate Steinle case was politicized and I
remember when people were so
disappointed that a jury found that the
man who was involved with her murder was
not convicted of anything except that
was he convicted of manslaughter maybe I
don't know but he was not convicted of
murder and I think so what we're looking
at though I think is the politics of it
and the politics of it play in a way
that I think you're going to see tonight
the president focus again on immigration
that's that was long stated to his theme
going into the midterms is what he wants
to focus on his therapist base and I
imagine this will play to it but the
thing is if he's right wait if what
happened if the incident occurs that
actually is part of something that
you've been talking about that's not
about playing into your base or saying
hey hey hey I'm right it's actually just
saying like this is a concern like
people confuse concern with politics
like if you could actually be concerned
about what about preventing such things
like this happening that's not a
political stance it's saying like this
is a problem the other thing about the
Kate Steinle
murderer I guess I shouldn't I don't
know if I can call now because I don't
remember what he was found guilty a look
at deflected bullet deported several
times and had returned we don't know
that about Christian Rivera yeah we know
he was he really gali but I don't know
if he was back and forth or if he had a
record I agree with you Greg and I want
I think you're reading this all wrong
it's not politicizing an issue for
American parents and people who have
friends and neighbors to look at a case
like this and say listen let's just look
at this rationally
yes not every person who enters the
country illegally is going to go on to
commit other crimes matter of fact very
few will I can see that point the bottom
line is 100 percent should not have been
here and if they weren't here this woman
if the allegations are true would be
alive that that's not irrational or
unreasonable and it's certainly not
politics for someone to see that in
Donald Trump as being an advocate for
their cause saying listen we've got to
get control I'll push back I sit here
and listen to that listen to Matt fin
talk about Molly tidbits and tears well
up in my eyes it is unavoidable and you
know what those tears aren't red or blue
they're from the heart and that's what
that mean is from the heart and the gut
so I don't think it's I don't think that
you can call it politicization and
saying that people will be more torn
apart by this then Michael Cohen's
guilty plea